you betrayed me he stole her from me Hey
ladies gentlemen's and fans that keep my
world going i'm here with aaron from
netherrealm studios the producer for
injustice gods among us now I played the
game I like I'm a huge mortal kombat man
everybody knows that uh but i noticed
that it's not a mortal kombat phone like
I thought it was going to be did you
want to move away from Mortal Kombat
what strange did you try to play on for
this game no that was absolutely one of
our goals I mean going into this game we
didn't want people to say it's just a
reskin Mortal Kombat you know one of the
nice things about working with the DC
Universe like this I mean obviously
we're proud of mortal kombat we love
Mortal Kombat but this gives us a little
bit of chance to you know kind of
breathe and try some new gameplay
elements and you know every time we make
a mortal kombat game there are things
that people expect and they want to see
like fatalities this gives us a chance
to try some new things so yeah we're
really excited to go in a little bit
different direction this time mortal
kombat vs DC was is it safe to say it
was a compromise and in this one is
everything that's strong about DC as
mortal kombat last time was everything
that was strong about Mortal Kombat yeah
well you know obviously with mortal
kombat vs DC we do have to find a way to
merge those two universes right so there
are going to be some restrictions there
it's got to make sense and still be a
fun fighting game this time around it
does absolutely allow us to just play to
the strengths of the DC license and the
brand and you know we've got all these
great characters that fans of the comics
are definitely going to love and all
their move sets are kind of tailored
around what the comic fans would expect
to see so like you mentioned flashing
his feet you know similarly like
Superman's powers are based around his
flight his strength that sort of thing
so I think fans that will definitely be
able to feel very right at very much at
home immediately upon playing the game
now ed boon netherrealm studios you guys
are I don't want to say notorious but
you are known for putting I'd say
cross-promotional characters in the
games do we get to see any of that like
Freddy Krueger and Kratos was in mortal
kombat and he surprises in this game you
know we're not quite ready to reveal the
full character roster of the game I mean
suffice to say again when you're dealing
with the entire DC Universe
hearing it down to a roster for a game
like ours was really difficult I I think
at the end people be very excited to see
the characters that we've included I
mean there's going to be some old
favorites some standbys but there's
going to be a few surprises in there as
well all right now this is you don't
have to even all right you are on record
I was going to say you're not on record
but you are on records are they new
Mortal Kombat character is going to show
their face in this maybe you know only
if it makes sense i mean obviously we're
also known for having surprises in our
games but you know we like there to be
some things for the players to find an
experience for the first time but I i
I'm not going to tell you for sure if
you're going to see an appearance by any
mortal kombat fan so i'm just going to
ask you to wait and see that is that's
the perfect answer right there she's not
going to kill you now is there a set
release date for this game goes it fall
summer 2013 2013 sometime in the next
year that big that is that is perfectly
vague but it's I really appreciate you
talking with me about this i love it
yeah so injustice gods among us not a
mortal kombat clone everything that's
great about the DC universe in a
fighting game check it out sometime in
2013